so Hollywood is full of self-righteous
hypocrites Oprah takes the Golden Globes
and wants to run for president and Steve
Bannon is still on the rocks with a very
stable genius I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
no Disneyland for anyone okay this
weekend was terrible it was just
terrible
it was mostly terrible because Hollywood
can't get over tough watching Hollywood
talk about sexual abuse and sexual
harassment is like watching NFL
executives talk about concussions and
then pat themselves on the back for it
it's just absurd but before we get to
any of that first I want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at blue apron
so blue apron is the leading meal
delivery kit service in the United
States in while many people know what
they do they don't know about the types
of meals that you can eat well they have
the best meals
I know because everyone in the office
uses blue aper they are the number one
fresh ingredient and recipe delivery
service in the country and their mission
is to make incredible home cooking
accessible to everyone so they send you
all the ingredients they send you the
recipes you cook at home it's healthier
it's better it's fresher they have three
plans the two-person meal plan and the
family meal plan and the wine plan the
two-person meal plan our meals that
serve two people choose eight new
recipes per week with the choice to
receive either two or three recipes any
week the family meal plan those are
meals that serve four people you can
choose from four new recipes per week
with the choice to receive either two
three or four recipes any week and the
wine plan six bottles of wine from
renowned wine makers delivered monthly
if all of this sounds awesome that's
because it is they are teaming with
whole 30 by the way to bring you
delicious recipes in their menu features
things like two whole thirty approved
recipes like Mexican spiced bar Emma
barramundi I don't even know what that
is but it sounds amazing with avocado
togarashi chicken lettuce cups of
avocado kale and sweet potato salad
kickstarters ear right with blue apron
and whole 30 okay you're gonna be eating
healthier blue apron is treating my
listeners to eight $30 off your first
order deal if you visit blue aprons comm
slash Shapiro that's blue apron dot-com
slash Shapiro again $30 off with free
shipping at blue apron comm slash appear
oh it is a better way to cook everybody
in the office is using it become a big
thing in LA I know it's also a big thing
in New York I have some relatives in New
York and they use blue apron or at least
they know a lot of people who use blue
apron that's because it's easier than
having to actually go down to a
restaurant instead the meals are
delivered right to them they cook it in
their house then have to schlep that
cart up and down the blocks in New York
City it's great for everywhere though
blue apron come again use that slash up
here Oh blue apron calm slash up here we
got 30 bucks off your first order and
when you do then you will be a then and
then you will also be letting them
know that we set you okay so I am very
annoyed always by these Hollywood events
these Hollywood events always annoy me
because I grew up in Hollywood and
Hollywood is filled with the most
self-righteous and yet despicable people
that you will ever meet in your life
Hollywood is filled with people who
engage in sexual harassment and abuse in
fact Hollywood as a town was built on
sexual harassment and abuse I don't mean
that figuratively I mean that the I
don't mean that an exaggerated fashion I
mean that a huge percentage of Hollywood
films a huge percentage of Hollywood
starlets got their starts on the
Hollywood casting couch virtually every
major producer in town at one time or
another has thrown his power around as
well as his genitals okay the idea that
this is not the dominant the predominant
mode of how casting is done in Hollywood
has been done for decades I think is is
a bit of a stretch the fact is Hollywood
is pretty degenerate it always has been
on these matters and there are a lot of
women who are willing to engage with
that knowing the risks knowing that they
were gonna come here and be sent to the
casting couch I've showed you in the
past films that make open jokes about
this all about Eve there's some open
jokes about Marilyn Monroe using the
casting couch okay this is not something
that is brand new from Hollywood well
Hollywood suddenly gets hit for it and
suddenly everyone's very surprised and
not only that that are their two virtue
signal it's just great they're there to
come along and signal to you not only
that they are wonderful leftist but also
that they are just shocked by an
appalled by what's happened in Hollywood
they're here to joke about all the
terrible things they've done as I said
at the top of the show
it's like watching NFL executives joke
about concussions or penn state
executives joke about pedophilia you
can't do this okay hollywood has an
entire event dedicated to patting itself
on the back for how much it's standing
up to the sexual harassment scandal
that's happening in its own industry and
to which many of the people who were who
are testifying last night or party in
the first place and we'll go through all
of this but let's start with Seth Meyers
his opening monologue so Seth Meyers
begins by slapping Holly wouldn't then
of course he has his obligatory slams
against Trump he's too lazy to actually
write any new jokes about trumps instead
he just hijacks jokes that were told
last year by Hugh Laurie I believe is
the Golden Globes about the Hollywood
Foreign Press Association here is Seth
Meyers again an overrated comedian who
who masquerades as a political thinker
here he is doing his opening monologue
ladies and remaining gentlemen there's a
new era underway and I can tell because
it's been years since a white man was
this nervous in Hollywood there's all
this is lazy there there's nothing
there's nothing new here and the idea I
look at we're all gonna laugh now about
white men being in power all gonna laugh
now about men being sexist we're all
gonna laugh about how men are on the run
in Hollywood except that half this crowd
cheered Roman Polanski half this crowd
stood up and cheered Woody Allen when he
won a white time Achievement Award from
the globe in Golden Globe six years ago
in 2012
Harvey Weinstein on this stage was
feeted as a god by Meryl Streep who last
night was talking about me too and
time's up and it's not just Seth Meyers
how he Debra Messing arrived and decided
it was time to slam a channel for the
so-called pay gap right the implication
being that he doesn't pay its female
hosts enough Debra Messing the
multi-millionaire who's a terrible
actress by the way and blocked me on
Twitter not because I just called her a
terrible actress but long ago and she
blocked me because I guess there an
incentive she would cancel her
subscription to The New York Times after
the New York Times did a profile of me
that did not rip me as racist because
I'm not Debra Messing decides that now's
a good time to virtually signal about
the pay gap she wasn't the only one by
the way what's the name of the lady um
well what's the name of the lady from
Friday Night Lights Oh Connie Britton
right so Connie Britton shows up last
night wearing a shirt that says
something like second something like
poverty is sexist it said poverty is
sexist the shirt cost $380 not a joke
$380 and after she spilled champagne on
it then it was worth $700 so well done
Connie Britton poverty Texas but she's
not the only hypocrite here's Debra
Messing a very very wealthy woman for
being a garbage actress on a show that
was really about the gay guy and about
the and about the shrill high-pitched
woman and not about her at all
here is Debra Messing talking about the
pay yeah Pat II you know I was so
shocked to hear that that
he doesn't believe in paying their their
female co-host the same as their male
co-host I mean I missed cat Sadler and
so we stand with her and that's
something that can change tomorrow so
much heroism so much strength so much
Normandy like bravery my god standing on
the red carpet wearing a probably a
gallon worth probably several thousand
dollars talking about the pay gap that
obviously is just brutal for women at E
whose entire job that consists of
standing alongside men and both of whom
talk about celebrities all day okay
let's be real about this women in the
entertainment industry in the talent
side of the entertainment industry are
not getting destroyed by sexism okay
they are in terms of sexual harassment
and sexual assault that's a different
issue but in terms of the pay gap here
the idea that Natalie Portman and
Jennifer Lawrence are being destroyed by
sexism or that the women II couldn't
just go to their bosses and say listen
either pay me more or I'll leave but
here's the thing about the free market
if you are easily replaceable and I'm
sorry to tell you this but women at E
and men and E are probably pretty
replaceable doesn't seem like a
particularly tough job then maybe you
ought to ask for a raise less often
rather than more often I mean if you
could start a neat Channel honestly and
pay everybody $30,000 a year and be
staffed up the wazoo
I mean there are people who are
beautiful working at coffee bean every
single day who would die to work for
$35,000 I don't coffee in pays maybe
it's more than that but there are people
who had died to be working on e and be
on TV every day for $35,000 in any case
there's never a messin complaining about
that mary j blige comes out and she says
you know in the new me to moment I will
kill you if you touch me but there's
something that she doesn't say which
kind of bothers me here here's mary j
blige oh I've had the fight since I was
5 years old I'm haven't haven't had
anybody approached me like that since
I've been in the music business but ever
since from 5 to 17 I've been going
through hell with sexual harassment so
you know by the time I got to the music
business it was like don't touch me you
know I'll kill you ok so first of all
that's that's great that she had that
attitude it's horrible what happened to
her as a child I would like to hear her
name the names of the guys who tried to
touch her in the music industry right
this is the one thing that was so
shocking about last night you watch all
of this and what you see over and over
and over is that nobody's willing to
name any names right they're just
willing to talk about broad problems
broad American sexism bro
sexual harassment but no one's willing
to name any names which means all these
guys get away with it and the half of
them are in the room I half of them are
in the room natalie portman I thought
was the most egregious offender last
night just in terms of being obnoxiously
smug she got something they're talking
about the all-male directors were
nominated which which women should have
been nominated last year that I mess
like patty Jenkins for Wonder Woman who
should have been nominated exactly in
any case here's Natalie Portman
suggesting and whining about all male
directors er honored to be here to
present the award for Best Director burn
Mitch's okay really what in the world
like oh my god how did what bravery
stunning stunning bravery Natalie
Portman worth millions and millions of
dollars for being not a very good
actress yeah Natalie Portman oh man she
struck back against the patriarchy at
that time boom roasted Hollywood is so
smug and so irritating I mean I'm famous
for being smug and they outclassed me by
orders of magnitude okay so before I go
any further and we'll talk about Oprah
because I have many other things you say
about Oprah Winfrey and her presidential
runs first I want to say thank you to
our sponsors over at filter by comm so
the holidays are over
but the winter has just begun according
to studies that means that you're going
to be inside a lot and the air indoors
contains up to a hundred times more
pollution than the air outside which can
cause illness allergies unnecessary wear
and tear on your HVAC system that's why
you need filter replacements okay it
doesn't it's not sexy topic but it is a
topic that is going to make your life a
lot better in some of the ways you will
not even notice until you come down not
with a flu right until you until you
don't get sick until you don't end up
hacking away in the middle of the winter
it filter by comm is America's leading
provider of HVAC HVAC filters for homes
and small businesses they carry over 600
different filter sizes including custom
options all shipped free within 24 hours
plus they are manufactured right here in
the United States they offer a multitude
of options all the way up to hospital
grade so you're gonna be getting rid of
the pollen and the mold and the dust and
the other allergy aggravating pollution
and maximizing the efficiency of your
system and right now you say 5% when you
set up auto delivery the great thing
about auto delivery is you forget about
your filters until I talk about them on
the show and then you buy the new
filters and you forget about them again
until they're all black with mold well
when you set up the auto delivery it
shows up at your door and you
have to worry about thinking about it
again it shows up you install them
you're done right right now you say 5%
when you set up auto delivery you never
need to think about it again go to
filter by calm breathe better filter bu
why.com
again that's filter by dot-com go check
it out I'll order ship free within 24
hours and again they have 600 size
options including custom sizes so go to
filter by comm and check it out alright
so all of this was prelude to the big
story of the evening the big story of
the evening was Oprah Winfrey Oh Oprah
so stunning so brave such stunning
bravery such brave X Thunder angry it's
just it's so so much bravery I can't
even take it I just can't take it in
fact it was so brave that everybody lost
their mind NBC tweeted that Oprah would
be our future president yes really the
network NBC they tweeted nothing but
respect for our future president hashtag
Golden Globes
our capital oh you are amazing just
amazing your future president is gonna
be a lady who is extraordinarily rich
very good at connecting with audiences
and who has and who's famous for
vacillating in her weight for years and
years
that's just great I mean honestly we
don't get to complain about reality TV
stars and self-made billionaires being
President of the United States because
the President of the United States is
those things right and then brags about
them on Twitter don't worry we'll get to
that in a little bit but she was just so
incredible last night she got up there
and she finally spoke truth to power
sure there are tons of pictures of her
kissing Harvey Weinstein sure there's an
actress who back in November alleged
that she fell into Harvey Weinstein
Weinstein's trap because she saw Oprah
hanging out with Harvey and figured
Harvey must be a good guy sure Oprah
Winfrey existed in this town for 30
years making doodles of cash becoming
the most powerful woman in media the
queen of all media and never had one
word to say about sexual harassment
assault in Hollywood sure all of that
true but the bravery the stunning miss
the stunning Miss Mick bravery ah just
shocking just stunning Reese Witherspoon
tweeted out in the midst of all of this
that Oprah Winfrey that she was now
going to date time differently she's
what she tweeted quote I will now
officially divide time like this
everything that happened before up her
speech everything that will happen after
my god it's just like Jesus it'll be Bo
and ayo before Oprah and after Oprah
just incredible time
things have changed things that can't
you feel the change in the air can't you
feel all the men backing away from the
sexual harassment interviews because
Oprah Winfrey got up and said some vague
words I do I feel like everything
changed last night now to be fair
Oprah's really good at this right Oprah
is actually a very good speaker she's
very talented she's quite a good actress
she's very good at connecting with
audiences we've known all this for years
she gets up Chris chalisa at CNN said
you could have heard her giving this
speech in Iowa you can almost imagine
her running for president have we
learned nothing people nothing right the
entire media that suggests that
inexperience is bad that we don't need
somebody with no policy that we don't
need somebody doesn't know what the hell
they're doing it they had a government
and they're like you know what we need
Oprah yeah
solid move okay so she give this speech
and everyone is just over the moon about
this speech it's just great she gets up
there and she finally says enough she
Oprah the queen of all media finally
says enough is enough now so I think
that's anything special no because I was
under the impression that we all felt
this way right I mean everybody showed
up to the Golden Globes last night
wearing black there's a class here of
Golden Globes and we've had in years it
wasn't people dressed like Lady Gaga
breaking out of an egg at the Golden
Globes red carpet everybody just looked
like it was the 1950s and they're
wearing black dresses actually everybody
kind of look classy maybe they should be
the going rule there from now on
but you know they but and everybody
shows up and they're talking on time's
up and me too and everybody's trying to
back away slowly from from anyone who is
remotely associated from Harvey
Weinstein and and Kevin Spacey and and
so I'm not sure what was so
groundbreaking about all this except
that people on Oprah to learn from run
for president they're talking about this
back in March and I'll go through it in
a few minutes
whether Oprah could actually win when
she runs for president but first I want
to go through the speech because it's
been treated as just grand and glorious
because she finally stood up for all the
victimized women throughout history and
over time Oprah Winfrey so stunning so
brave here we go shoot there a few
problems she starts off by talking about
how she is exactly the same as Sidney
Poitier in 1964 right Sidney pointy had
won a Golden Globe I guess in 1964 and
and she said she watched it on TV or she
wanted out he won an Oscar I guess in
1964 maybe four in the heat of the night
in any case she she says this yeah just
got clipped one yeah
82 simply received the Cecil B deMille
Award right here at the Golden Globes
and it is not lost on me that at this
moment there are some little girls
watching as I become the first black
woman to be given the same award name
them name them seriously name the lives
of the little black girls whose lives
were changed because they saw Oprah
Winfrey win this award not by Oprah
Winfrey making three billion dollars
over the course of her career not by
Oprah Winfrey become the most powerful
woman in media over the past 30 years
not by Michelle Obama being first lady
or Susan Rice being National Security
Advisor or Loretta Lynch being Attorney
General or kind of Lisa rice being
Secretary of State not by any of those
things right not not by it not by any of
these famous black women being in
positions of powers for years not by the
fact that the music industry is
dominated by powerful black women not by
Beyonce not by the fact that the the
entertainment industry is dominated by
beautiful black women and powerful black
women not by the fact that women DOM
black women dominate sports not by Venus
Williams or Serena Williams not by any
of those people
it was Oprah winning a Golden Globe last
night that changed everything people it
changed everything hey let me tell you
black girls who are watching TV today
they are in exactly the same situation
as she was in 1964 watching Sidney
Poitier and his white tie and black skin
this is her words get up and say what he
says at the at the Oscars or at the
Golden Globes right then that it's
exactly the same issue is 64 2018
exactly the same now I hate this kind of
virtue signaling I really do because
2018 to pretend this is exactly the same
is not remotely true it's stupid it's
overblown and to pretend this some sort
of groundbreaking moment is just sheer
crap eree it's just nonsense it's just
stupidity okay but you didn't stop there
right in her in her effort to garner
support for her 2020 run then she
thanked the Hollywood Foreign Press and
I love this this still frame of Barbra
Streisand I think is pretty fitting
actually so when they just leave that
but there is there is Barbra Streisand
with I guess who's that is that James
Brolin I'm not sure who that guy is
maybe not James Brolin no okay in any
case here is here's Oprah Winfrey
talking about the Hollywood Foreign
Press and the power of the press how
special the press is they are so special
people
let Oprah tell you about it I want to
say that I value the press more than
ever
before as we try to navigate these
complicated times yes just yes I mean
and the people nodding and the people
cheering yes the press oh okay let me
explain to you something about the
foreign the Hollywood Foreign Press
Association the Hollywood Foreign Press
Association is 90 international
reporters you know they do all they then
report on Hollywood is what they do this
is what the Hollywood Foreign Press
Association is you know what might have
been a good story about Hollywood you
know for like the past 80 years any time
in here you know I'm in a good story for
them to report on the rampant sexual
abuse and harassment that took place in
Hollywood for decades by the most
powerful men in the business that might
have been a good thing did they speak to
the power did they uncover the secrets
and the lies and the victims and the
tyrants did they do that she wants to
thank the Hollywood Foreign Press for
speaking up for truth good job guys you
were just you're just brilliant you're
just fantastic wonderful job I am so
impressed legitimately the only members
of the press who did anything about the
about the rampant Hollywood abuse for
people like Ronan Farrow right people
over at The New Yorker did some great
work on this but the Hollywood Foreign
Press Association did nothing right I
mean the idea that they're being feeded
is some some great truth tellers in a
world of lies is just ridiculous also I
will acknowledge that the entire left
focus on the power of the media and the
power of the press aside from when they
can rip on the Catholic Church like they
praise the press for going after the
Catholic Church for its sex abuse
scandals I don't remember them being
quite so over-the-moon about the power
and necessary necessary wonder of the
press during the Obama administration
now we get movies like the post which I
gotta say I have no desire to see this
movie because the if the if the pray ler
is that tenth inchess and obnoxious I
cannot imagine that the movie is going
to be any better than that I mean it is
the most obnoxious trailer in human
history Meryl Streep ha ho oh you just
watch me as I take on all the brutal men
in the government and Tom Hanks rubbing
her shoulders while she does so it just
looks like a terrible movie I'll have to
watch it and tell you how terrible
because now I've committed myself in any
case that wasn't the end of Oprah
Winfrey and her and her glorious grand
bravery ridden speech here she talks
about speaking your truth
my least favorite phrase in all of human
history speaking your truth here we go
what I know
sure is that speaking your truth is the
most powerful tool we all have and I was
specially proud and inspired by all the
women who have felt strong enough and
empowered enough to speak up and shoot
not a shot of Meryl Streep okay Oprah's
great at this and she and I'm sure she's
really emotional about this
you know I let's put this way because
I'm not captain emotion I always get
suspicious of emotion on cue but I'm
sure she's really emotional about this
she had a really rough childhood did
Oprah Winfrey I'm sure that her mother
endured a lot of stuff all that said
that phrase speaking your truth is so
obnoxious and then say speak your truth
and have a shot of Meryl Streep Meryl
Streep like Harvey Weinstein is a god
Meryl Streep that's that's how the press
treat this okay there's no such thing as
your truth I've said this a thousand
times there's no such thing as your
truth there is the truth and your
opinion and when you say speaking your
truth that requires evidence
okay evidence would be a good thing now
I believe women who make these
allegations as a general rule I do but I
have to weigh the evidence I have to
weigh how credible the women are I have
to weigh whether there are repeat
accusations I have to repeat and I have
to review the nature of the man I
actually have to look at the evidence on
all of these accusations but this phrase
speaking your truth needs to die and
needs to die slowly and horribly in the
torture chamber used in the Princess
Bride for Wesley okay it needs to die
that phrase speaking your truth is just
garbage even people on the left are
recognizing that it undermines their
arguments to say that okay but that's
not the end of Oprah's Oprah's silly
okay there's a there's fun again there's
a lot in this speech to like there is I
mean like sexual harassment bad right
I'm on the side of that if I've not been
clear about that I've been saying this
for months okay in four years and four
decades earlier my entire career but I'm
gonna get to the what I think was the
worst injustice that she did last night
Oprah Winfrey in this speech in just a
second first I want to say thank you to
our sponsors over at stamps.com so here
is a new year's resolution you can
actually keep ad stamps calm to your
business and save a ton of time and
money this year so here at the office we
use stamps calm not just because we save
money on our stamps but stamps that calm
has postage discounts that you cannot
get at the post office it means that the
people who work here don't have to rush
on down to the post office every time we
need stamps and wait in line it means
that you get all of those special
discounts it means that you get to have
your own scale you can weigh or
postage we use stamps calm here at the
Daily wire and stamps calm does bring
all the amazing services of the US
Postal Service right there to your
computer it's the better way to get
postage you use your computer you can
print us vote postage on any letter or
package any class of mail and then the
mailman picks it up and leaving the
office
no lugging mail to the post office no
more hassle by the way the the postage
discounts also mean that it's a fraction
of the cost of those super expensive
postage meters when you get your own
postage meter through stamps.com they
will send you a digital scale that
automatically calculates exact postage
which means you'll never overpay or
under pay for postage again right it's
convenient it's easy it is reliable and
it is efficient so check it out
stamps com and they have a special offer
right now including a four week trial
plus postage and a digital scale if
you're ready for a better New Year go to
stamps com click on the microphone at
the top of the page and type in Shapiro
that stamps comm and use the promo code
Shapiro use that microphone click on it
use your pair you get that four-week
trial plus postage and digital scale and
it really is a terrific deal use that
promo code Shapiro also so that they
know that we sent you okay so concluding
Oprah Winfrey's masterful stunningly mad
brave speech I'm just gonna keep using
those those words over and over because
that's what the media does I mean if I
read you the headlines on Oprah now I'm
gonna be forced to read you the
headlines on Oprah okay I'm just going
like right now in real-time to Google
News
Oprah knew exactly what she was doing on
Sunday night CNN HuffPo Oprah and
Stedman hid she's open to presidential
run sources Oprah Winfrey actively
thinking about running for president
right Golden Globes 2018 how Oprah saved
the night
Oprah 2020 Golden Globes host Seth
Meyers jokes it may be in the cards
Oprah Winfrey triumphs have blacked
raped Golden Globes I mean just Oprah
speaks out to young girls and sessile B
deMille Award speech just so much
heroism so much hair wasn't speaking in
a room full of other rich people who all
are forced to agree with her by the news
cycle about everything because if they
don't then we'll all accuse them of
sexual abuse or being complicit in it I
mean the thing about speaking truth to
power is it would be good to do that
when there's actual risk involved she
was the most powerful person in the
media for the last 20 years she did not
say a thing about this happening in
Hollywood a thing and now she's being
used as the point person on this she's
the queen of bravery he's like Roger
Goodell saying he's taking the lead
concussions I keep using that because
it's the best example I can think of
it's like the president of Penn State
saying he's taking the lead on child
sexual abuse hey you can't do that
it's just ridiculous it's hypocritical
and ridiculous and again I agree with
everything she's saying I agree but
where was she
six months ago hey not even that long
ago hey here here this is the part that
really dragged nipple wall so she
actually compares women who are being
victimized in Hollywood to a woman who's
raped by six men six white men in 1944
black woman raped in Alabama and the
guys were not prosecuted for it here is
here she is talking about it
in 1944 resi Taylor was a young wife and
a mother she was just walking home from
a church service she'd attended in
Abbeville Alabama when she was abducted
by six armed white men raped and left
blindfolded by the side of the road for
too long women have not been heard or
believed if they dared to speak their
truth to the power of those men but
their time is up
oh so much emotional lecture us
Hollywood lecture us on this right
lecture us because it's not like you are
the scandal why yeah you watch for me
Oprah yeah you lecture me I wasn't the
one who was wining and dining with you
know Harvey Weinstein five seconds ago
the hypocrisy of it just drives me up a
wall listen I'm glad that Hollywood is
finally owning up to the issue so I
think there's gonna be any material
change in Hollywood by the way no I
think there's all gonna die down in six
months and things will go back right to
what they were before because no one's
naming names does Oprah have a rolodex
she knows all these guys she had
anything to say about any of them a name
one how about that and the part of the
drives maple wall here is the
implication that America in 1944 is the
same as America in 2018 with regard to
allegations of rape particularly cross
cross cross racial rape cave a group of
white men raped a black woman not only
would be front-page story across the
nation the president would sound off
every person in America would be calling
for those guys to be strung up how do I
know because it was a national scandal
when Al Sharpton claimed that Tawana
Brawley falsely was raped by a bunch of
white men it was a national scandal when
the Duke Lacrosse guys were falsely
accused to have raped crystal Mangum
who
black stripper in in Duke and when and
when a when that actually happens we
want those guys do won't wait forever to
pretend the society now in society then
are in any way similar and she said in
and that the me2 movement is what
changed that guess what the media
movement didn't change that everyone was
against rape and everyone is still
against rape we were against rape we are
against rape we will be against rape for
my entire lifetime and this pretend
nonsense then 1944 is the same is now or
that requires the same kind of bravery
no one should compare resi Taylor to
Oprah Winfrey okay nobody should be
comparing Rosa Parks to Meryl Streep if
you argue out of your mind you're out of
your mind and pretend to compare America
circa an Alabama circa 1944 with America
circa 2018 in Hollywood the repository
of all the sexual abuse is just vomit
Tricia's it's just a bag of vomit
hey now there's a lot of talk about
Oprah should run for president off the
basis of it so I'll just because so
because again what courage what
unbelievable courage by the way I did
note this last night and a bunch of
people got mad at me for saying so but
you won't how many times do Ron
mentioned last night waiting III didn't
see a mention once did anybody else I
didn't watch the whole program because
I'd rather gouge out my eyes with a
spork but if you actually were watching
this thing was Ron mentioned guy I like
when she says we side with women all
over the world that would have been a
good time to talk about maybe places
around the world where women are being
routinely victimized not just in the
United States and Oprah by the way cares
about things happening around the world
she founded a school for girls in South
Africa right she actually cares about
stuff happening outside the United
States wouldn't now been a good time in
that speech to say not just women here
but women in Iran and women in Saudi
Arabia and women in Egypt and women in
in a right couldn't you have just listed
those off in the middle of it but no
because Hollywood is is deeply invested
in Hollywood itself and they and they
have to show that they're leading the
fight against themselves which of course
is not true at all okay so would Oprah
Winfrey win a presidential election
number one the person hardest hit last
night is Joe Biden because Oprah Winfrey
would win the primaries Oprah Winfrey
would obviously win the primaries right
Joe Biden would get shellacked by Oprah
Winfrey not just because Oprah Winfrey
is black but because Oprah Winfrey is
deeply talented and she spent 30 years
building up a stock of goodwill with the
American people and particularly with
women so let's talk more about the
general election because I think that
I ran she would almost assuredly win the
Democratic primary nomination process
could she beat Donald Trump so here's
what she's got going forward they're
about five arguments in favor and five
arguments against first she is the most
famous woman in the history of mankind
that's not really an exaggeration she's
the most famous woman in media she is
this is a time when people have access
to information about other people and a
rate never before known by man she's the
most famous person ever right she's so
famous that Donald Trump has spent years
praising her in April 2012 quote M Oprah
will end up doing just fine with her
network she knows how to win may 2014
the greatest discovery of all time is
that a person can change his future by
merely changing his attitude at Oprah
Winfrey right say so he's so so you know
she they're a bunch of arguments here uh
in favor of Oprah she's uniter not a
divider right her whole brand is I bring
people together i unite people I make
people happy right she is the she's the
warm and fuzzy whereas Trump's whole
brand is firing people and acting tough
so Oprah there would never be a bigger
gender gap than Oprah versus Trump right
there'd be the gender gap would be
enormous would be like ninety ten for
women for Oprah and ninety ten for men
for Trump it would be an enormous
enormous gender gap and then it goes on
here I mean I'm gonna continue in just a
second talking about what exactly what
it what exactly her qualifications
problems are her other qualifications
here third qualification she has a
terrific personal story right so she her
personal story is really good I'm like
Trump who grew up SuperDuper wealthy and
then became SuperDuper more wealthy
largely through branding power she was
born legitimately dirt poor in
Mississippi to a single mom raised in
inner-city Milwaukee molested as a child
pregnant at 14 she apparently
miscarriage she got in a radio at 19 and
made herself worth three billion dollars
and so her personal story is terrific
she definitely checks the left
intersectionality boxes so she gets to
say woman black over and over and that's
what the left will on to the DNC
yesterday tweeted out what will qualify
women for office what would qualify a
woman for what would qualify won't
qualify someone for office said we need
to elect more and then entitle the whole
list Jewish women Asian women black
women lesbians and just all transgender
women like a whole list and said we need
more women so when it comes to the left
of view of what qualifies a person for
office Oprah's high on the list right
black and woman she also has crossover
appeal in a way that for example ho for
example Hillary Clinton
right Hillary was a woman but other
women didn't like our Oprah's woman that
other women really like a lot she pulls
well also by the way in as a March 2017
she had a 49:33 favorable rating
honestly I'm shocked at her favorable
rating is that low I would think it
would be closer in the 50s she led Trump
and actually pulled her against Trump
and she leads Trump right now 47 40 in
the polls which is not a blowout by the
way and that's more like Hillary Clinton
numbers than anything else so here are
the drawbacks here's why Oprah would
probably not win if she ran one she's
wildly inexperienced now that doesn't
hold a lot of stock anymore in the last
two presidents have had no experience
basically entering high office Donald
Trump had legitimately no experience
entering high office Oprah has run her
own business in the way Trump has gonna
be hard for him to say you have no
experience when he had no experience she
is far left her politics will become an
issue here now she wants to run as great
uniter I'm the person who everybody
agrees is emotionally connected and that
doesn't hold once you start running once
you start running you become a
polarizing political figure pretty
quickly and she is pretty far to the
left she endorsed Obama in the 2008
primaries it probably helped him win the
primaries over Hillary Clinton she
traveled to Denmark in 2009 and openly
praised socialism she's compared Trayvon
Martin to Emmett Till here which is
again just insane she's a pro-choice
advocate she's made statements in the
past like there have been millions of
lynchings in the United States which of
course isn't true about 4,000 lynchings
as far as I'm aware which of course is
terrible but then she has suggested a
connection between the time of lynchings
and and now right well by comparing
Emmett Till to Trayvon Martin nobody
thinks of Oprah's political but those
politics will jump to the floor pretty
quickly as soon as she starts running
she also is kind of kooky I mean people
say the Trump is a conspiracy theorist
Oprah's kind of a kook yeah I know
everybody wants to bury that but aside
from her various weight loss theories
she hosted Jenny McCarthy on vaccines
numerous times she pushed if you recall
the New Age silliness of the secret
which was this idea that through the
power of positive thinking we could heal
yourself and then it became a national
scandal when one woman who had cancer
said I'm gonna use the power of positive
thinking to heal my cancer it did not
work it was a failed right she went out
and defended the fraudster James Frey as
you recall there was major scandal for
her she pushed nonsense about the meat
industry that had the meat industry
actually suing her so you know look
Trump is a conspiracy theorist too in a
lot of ways but the difference
is that Trump is already so filled with
mud right he's covered with mud he's a
mud monster that throwing more mud on
Trump doesn't do have any damage oprah
is considered this sort of angelic
character and that means that if you
throw mud at an angel you're more likely
to the spots were more likely to show on
the dress right so then there are also
scandals that are going to hit her as
well so every person has scandals in
their past Oprah has some pretty bad
ones the worst one was in 2009 her
school that she runs in Johannesburg
South Africa the Oprah Winfrey
Leadership Academy School for Girls
it was hit with the sex scandal a sexual
abuse scandal actually two of them in
two years so in 2009 there's a series of
the students who were sexually abused by
other students the year before there's a
matron who allegedly sexually abused 15
girls right she actually fought back by
firing the headmistress and all the
matrons and giving the girls her cell
phone number but there will be digging
into how much did she know was she fully
aware of it at the time right the story
sort of went away because she took the
right measures but scandals hurt
everyone if they hurt Mitt Romney they
certainly hurt Oprah Winfrey finally
Oprah versus Trump Oprah would end up
school alarming Trump a lot and she'd
end up doing a lot of what Hillary
Clinton did she'd end up standing there
going hunting him for his for his
baseness and his cruelty it didn't work
well for for Hillary now Oprah doing it
might be more successful but I'm not
sure schoolmarm works against Trump in
any case so before everybody gets over
the moon about Hillary for president I
just I think there's some real holes in
that particular theory I also think that
the Democrats are probably gonna
nominate somebody who's more akin to Joe
Biden okay meanwhile putting aside the
Golden Globes now let's talk about
president Trump's tweets so over the
weekend President Trump had a lot to say
about this book alright so over the
weekend there is there's a lot to say
for president Trump about the the this
this wolf Michael Wolf book fire and
fury well talk about you know we'll talk
about that in just a second but for this
for for the discussion of very stable
geniuses and Steven Miller on CNN you're
gonna have to go over to Daley wire calm
right now and subscribe for $9.99 a
month you can have a subscription to
daily wire calm when you get that
subscription you get the rest of this
show live you get to be part of my
mailbag on Fridays you will also get
discounts from the soon to be coming
Shapiro's store you will get the rest of
Michael Noel's a show you'll get the
rest of Andrew clavin's show you'll get
all of those glories for $9.99 a month
for $99 a year a significant discount
from the monthly fee time to get the
wheels turning and the keyboards humming
on Tues
day January 16th at 5 p.m. Eastern 2
p.m. Pacific we'll be doing our fifth
episode of the conversation
featuring the daily wire zone Andrew
Clavin moderated by our own host Alicia
Kraus subscribe today be part of the
conversation ask through those live
questions which you will answer for
everyone to hear make your life better
in every conceivable way Drew's
conversation will stream live on the
daily wire Facebook page and the daily
wire YouTube channel it'll be free for
everyone to watch only subscribers get
to ask the questions to ask questions as
a subscriber you log into our website
daily we're calm you head over to the
conversation page to watch the live
stream after that if you just start
typing into the daily wired chat box
drew will answer questions as they come
in for an entire hour once again
subscribe to get your questions answered
by drew on Tuesday January 16th 5 p.m.
Eastern 2 p.m. Pacific and join the
conversation
Andrew Clavin this time you get all of
those things and you get this extra
goodie the leftist year is hot or cold
tumblr the greatest of all beverage
vessels yes greater than any beverage
vessel that was held at the Golden
Globes last night it is phenomenal and
you get all of those things for 99
dollars a year you just want to listen
later head over to SoundCloud iTunes
YouTube please subscribe to our YouTube
channel we always appreciate it we put
up videos every day pretty much
they won't see anywhere else so check
that out on our YouTube channel we are
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
all righty so the big controversy over
the weekend is that the Michael Wolfe
book about Donald Trump was making the
rounds the reason I was making the
rounds the new case against Trump is not
that he's a Russian collude or it said
he's a nutjob
now let's be frank about this this has
been a case against Trump for at least
several years and the Donald Trump is
not the most mentally stable human and
if you follow his twitter feed I'm not
gonna lie to you
he doesn't look like he is emotionally
centered shall we put it that way
he's not exactly a practitioner of the
art of the Dow he's not somebody who
with a Buddhist sense of passivity and
Donald Trump is a guy who sounds off a
lot and he's very vile at all and
everybody knows this and there's a lot
of talk in this Michael Wolfe book about
how Trump is actually a crazy person
right how he's actually mentally
unstable well Trump decided to fight
back against this in the most stable
possible way he went on Twitter and
mouthed off about it here's what he said
quote now that Russian collusion after
one year of intense study has proven to
be a total hoax on the American public
the Democrats in their lapdogs the fake
news mainstream media are taking out the
old Ronald Reagan playbook and screaming
mental stability and intelligence and he
continues along these lines he says
actually throughout my life my two
greatest assets have been mental
stability and being like really smart
the like is actually in they're not
making that up it says being comma like
comma really smart
crooked Hillary Clinton also played
these cards very hard and as everyone
knows went down in flames I went from a
very successful businessman to top TV
star and then he continues to President
of the United States in parentheses on
my first try
technically not his first try he ran for
the Reform Party nomination I believe in
2000 he said I think that would qualify
it is not smart but genius and a very
stable genius at that okay a few
comments on this if you are trying to
demonstrate that you are a very stable
genius you should not do it like this
you should not the funniest thing I saw
about this was that somebody tweeted out
a picture of mr. Edie with the caption
stable genius
I like puns salad salad work but here's
the problem if you want to show that
you're smart and you deserve respect you
should not go full fredo in Godfather 2
and demand respect
yeah and that's sort of everybody's
reaction right Michael's reaction
there's pretty much the reaction shot
for everybody after Trump tweets all of
that now you can talk about whether you
think he's stable you can talk about
whether you think he's qualified to be
president you can talk about all the
good things that have happened under
under Trump and I agree with all the
Trump
I've been if I've not been clear about
that I really like the last eight weeks
of policy particularly but if you want
to show that you are actually a very
stable genius do not channel Fredo it's
just not a bright thing to do like
advice to President Trump please for the
love of God put down the phone just put
it down
you know what would convey that you're
to a very stable genius putting down the
phone putting it down like now put it
down I have to I feel like I'm talking
to my year and a half year old son put
down the pone where he calls it a pone
put down the pone okay just stop when he
does this it is not helpful the reason
that it's particularly unhelpful is
because right now he's trying to fight
back all of these allegations and not
just that you know there are a lot of
people on my side of the aisle on the
conservative side will say listen who
cares how he acts all that cares is what
gets done the reason people are
considering Oprah Winfrey for president
is because of how she acts not because
of what they think she's going to get
done
if the reality is what we perceive the
presidential election to be who we
perceive the president to be is what
from what Trump evidence is in his
tweets not what he does in his policy we
can justify his presidency to ourselves
by talking about all the things he does
in policy and that's great that's how I
see the presidency in my dreams right
the presidency should be about the
policies the promulgate but that's not
what exactly people see the presidency
has they see the presidency as the stuff
you say and Trump is saying silly silly
things and not just that he then
activates Stephen Miller to go out on
CNN now Stephen Miller had some words to
say about ski Bannen I agree with all of
his words he called Steve Danon
grotesque agreed he called Steve Danon
ridiculous agreed right and I know Steve
Miller I know Steven Miller I think
Stephen is a very knowledgeable guy
particularly at immigration but on TV he
is just television poison he is just bad
on TV if you want Stephen Miller to
basically go after Steve Annan a
statement from Steve Miller a public
statement from Stephen Miller released
as a video would
much better instead he goes had it with
Jake Tapper and here's the problem when
I agree with what you're saying and I'm
still criticizing how you're saying it
it might be a problem with how you're
saying it so Stephen Miller goes on with
tapper and he refuses to answer any
simple questions which he could write I
could have done a better job ripping on
Bandhan in this interview then Miller
does Miller goes out there and instead
he just devotes 12 minutes to making a
fool of himself and it's just not useful
it's just not good and then he ends up
being success courted from the CNN
headquarters by security if you're
trying to evidence that you guys are all
very stable geniuses know just know
here's some of this now I know that
Trump tweeted out that he loves this I
know the Trump tweeted out that that he
thinks that this was just a great
performance by Stephen Miller it was not
okay here I will show you with respect
to the Trump Tower meeting that he's
talking about he wasn't even there when
and this went down so he's not really a
remotely credible source on any of it it
reads like an angry vindictive person
spouting off to a highly discredit
author the book is best understood as a
work of very poorly written fiction and
I also will say that the author is a
garbage author of a garbage book a
phenomenon was happening that you didn't
see a phenomenon was happening that the
rest of the political class didn't see
all these so-called political geniuses
in Washington whether it be at the big
you´d lobbying firms or the only genius
in the last week is the president but
you big guys happens to be a true
statement okay it's self-made
billionaire who revolutionized reality
TV you just want to say that the book is
just a grotesque if you want to just say
the book is fiction that's fine but this
whole we got to go on TV and we got to
treat the president like he's kim
jeong-hoon we're gonna go around
worshiping we're actually gonna get out
a prayer rug and just bow down to trump
he is a genius he's the only one who was
a genius he beat 17 other candidates
bubble come on okay like if you think
this is helpful to Trump's prospects in
2020 you got another thing coming okay
in a second we are going to get to some
things I like and some things that I
don't you know let's just do it okay so
I'm time for some things I like some
things I hate and then we will do some
Federalist Papers so things I like over
the weekend
I got to see Jumanji it is fun okay it's
not Citizen Kane it's not meant to be
Citizen Kane it is very funny I was
actually kind of shocked
they didn't use the rock in more comedic
ways the people who are actually funny
in this in this film are Jack Black and
Kevin Hart Jack Black is very funny he
basically the basic premise of the film
is that there are these four teenagers
who entered the game Jumanji if you
remember the original Jumanji it was the
opposite right it was it was Robin
Williams pops out of the game and said
all the animals and is freakin out the
kids and I remember it was pitched as a
kid-friendly film the original Jumanji
and I when I saw it and I was like eight
it freaked the living crap out of me
right it's actual very freaky film this
one is obviously pitched to people who
are like 16 years old 15 and a episodes
it is pg-13 and it should be pg-13 so in
any case here is a little bit of preview
Spencer that's a new fridge Martha
you're all here for a reason you should
be thinking about who you are and who
you want to pay you'll have plenty of
time to figure that out while you're
cleaning out the basement are you gonna
help
are you too pretty I'm too pretty yo
what's this a game for those who seek to
find a way to leave their world behind
Jumanji pick a character
and you're that person in the game we're
okay I don't think it matters how much
you spin ball sounds like it better than
I'll be the curvy genius under smolder
rave stop guessing Ruby roundhouse
and then of course the it's not spoiling
anything but the funny thing is the
characters they'd have it so the the big
black football player ends up being
Kevin Hart right tiny and the nerd ends
up being being the Dwayne the rock
Johnson and then of course the big
surprise is that the the hot blonde
chick ends up being Jack Black right and
so the entire film Jack Black is
basically channeling a teenage girl and
it's and it is quite funny so the movies
really enjoyable I saw with my wife it's
it's a good way to lose a couple of
hours it is it is it's got its moments
it definitely has its moments you know I
I feel I always feel this with comedies
third where I see a comedy and I feel
like it couldn't gotten a little bit
more from it but you get enough from it
that you're that you're pretty pleased
with it so it's pretty it's pretty funny
so check it out Jumanji worth seeing
Dwayne the rock Johnson only makes films
that are that are funny and interesting
actually I actually I have to say I've
become a big fan of the rock okay I will
even watch Central Intelligence and
think that's a good movie because I
think that Dwayne the rock Johnson is
very funny human okay so check that out
okay other things that you know what I
want to spend some time on the
Federalist Papers here so I'm just gonna
skip right over things I hate guess what
too bad okay so let's talk Federalist
Papers the reason I wanna spend some
extra time today is because this is one
of the more important Federalist Papers
every week we do a Federalist paper
today we are in Federalist number 10
this is one of the most famous this one
is by James Madison this is the one
where he talks about how the
organization of the Constitution of the
United States helps defeat the power of
faction so what he says is by affection
I understand a number of citizens
whether amounting to a majority or a
minority of the whole are united and
actuated by some common impulse of
passion or of interest adverse to the
rights of other citizens or to the
permanent aggregate interests of the
community so what he says basically a
faction is any political group of people
organizing against another group of
people or organizing against a future
interest he says there are two methods
of curing the mischiefs of fashion and
one of faction the one by removing its
causes the other by controlling its
effects there are again two methods of
removing the causes of factions the one
by destroying the Liberty which is
essential to its existence the other by
giving to every citizen the same
opinions the same passions and the same
interest so here's what he says he says
basically if you want to stop factions
from tearing a society apart for its top
the majority from hurting the minority
or the minority from hurting the
majority there are only two ways of
doing that the one is to get rid
of the causes of faction so make
everybody think the same way the other
is by controlling its effects if you
want to get rid of everybody thinking
differently the only way to do that is
by getting rid of Liberty on the one
hand or by giving every citizen the same
opinions the same passions the same
interest through training he says that
the the getting rid of the causes is a
fool's errand
he says if you destroy Liberty that's
worse than the disease he says Liberty
is to faction what air is to fire an
ailment without which it instantly
expires he says that getting rid of
Liberty is like getting rid of air
because you want to get rid of bad
animals you get rid of all animals he
says that also having everybody agree is
unwise he says as long as the reason of
man continues fallible and he has
Liberty to exercise at different
opinions will be formed and as long as
the connection subsists between his
reason and his self-love his opinion and
his passions will have a reciprocal
influence on one another and the former
will be obvious to which the latter will
attach themselves in other words what
he's saying is even if you could try to
reason everybody to the proper solutions
people are actually not driven by reason
they're driven by passion and then they
make excuses for the passions that they
seek in politics he also points out
faction is not gonna be cured basically
without fascism he actually dramatically
foresees Marx he says that there will
always be material inequality in a free
society because people have different
abilities he said the diversity and the
faculties of men from which the rights
of property originate is not less and
insuperable obstacle to a uniformity of
interests he says we're always going to
fall into mutual animosities based on
our varying viewpoints and different
abilities and he says the legislation
means that we're judges in our own case
rights if you were going to judge
between the rich and the poor you really
can't have them just vote on it because
now you're a judge in your own case so
what do we have to do that leaves us
with the second solution and that is we
have to control its effect so if we have
a minority seeking to impose on the
majority we don't have a problem right
because minority can't impose on the
majority but what if a majority wants to
impose him on a minority then we have a
serious problem and he says no informal
checks and balances will suffice he says
either the existence of the same passion
or interest in a majority at the same
time must be prevented or the majority
having such coexistent passion or
interest must be rendered by number and
local situation unable to concert and
carry into effect schemes of oppression
so he what he says is if you have a big
republic with lots of varying interest
it's hard to actually motivate a
majority to curb the rights of others
he says pure democracy is gonna fail
because in a pure democracy you can just
have the majority all over the place
vote
from one policy but a republic is better
right and then he differentiates between
a democracy and a republic this is very
very important the reason it's important
is because you'll hear people say stupid
things like America is a democracy
America is not a democracy it's a
republic or there's no difference
between American democracy and an
American Republic there are two major
differences in Madison's spells them out
clearly says first the delegation of the
government in the latter in the Republic
to a small number of citizens elected by
the rest secondly the greater number of
citizens and greater sphere of country
over which the latter may be extended so
you can have a bigger Republic than you
can have a democracy very hard to have a
democracy of 300 million he's having 300
million people vote on any topic is
gonna fail it's hard to even get people
to vote for local dog catcher so what he
says as far as the number of legislators
first you can't have too many and you
can't have too few if you have too few
it begins to become in Oleg Archy and if
you have too many it's hard to get
anything done and then he says also a
large Republic means that it will be
difficult to coordinate interests in a
small Republic you could have a majority
that elects a couple of politicians and
they become dictators but in a large
majority in a large Republic it's hard
to get all of the interests to
coordinate its is the smaller the
Society the fewer probably will be the
distinct parties and interests composing
it the fewer of the distinct parties and
interests the more frequently will
majority be found of the same party and
the smaller the number a number of
individuals composing that majority the
smaller the compass within which they
are placed so it's easy to become
oppressive right instead he says we need
localism on most levels but broader
republicanism for the big stuff he says
the influence of factious leaders make
hens will flame within particular states
but will be unable to spread a general
complicated conflagration through the
through the other states a religious
sect made to generate into a political
faction in part of the Confederacy but
the variety of sects dispersed over the
entire face of it must secure the
National councils against any danger
from that source you won't have Catholic
rule or Mormon rule or Jewish rule or
Protestant rule in the United States
because there's too much diversity he
says any bad policy should basically be
canceled out any oppressive policy
should be canceled out now this was
largely true in the United States except
for the massive injustice of slavery in
which federalism prevented the
imposition of a better policy on the
states right it was a a two-edged sword
if there was bad policy in the States
the federal government didn't really
have the capacity to stop it
but if there was bad policy in the
States
some other ways then the federal
government also didn't become that
policy right the federal government was
never dominated by slaveholders it was
dominated by people who were in favor of
the states having their own policy on it
which is not quite the same thing in
fact it is but in practice but in in
theory it is not in any case the whole
point here is that the diversity of
viewpoints makes for a large republic a
more Liberty oriented system right you
are you're not getting rid of faction
per se so when people lament faction
itself that's silly you can't get rid of
faction but you can control its effects
that's what Federalist number 10 is
about and Madison very clearly lays out
why okay so we will be back we will be
back here at tomorrow with all of the
latest news and we look forward to
seeing of that i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex singhara audio is mixed
by Mike or Mina hair and makeup is by
Jess while alvera the Ben Shapiro show
is a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for publishing 2017